E aí
[Música]
O que é que tem três características em
comum entre a medicina EA música pois
bem A primeira é muito fácil andas as
palavras medicina em música começam pela
letra m a segunda característica é que
tem um vídeo é uma competência essencial
para estas duas profissões quero música
Quero médico necessitam de ter um
convite ou seja o músico Por que
necessita de saber discriminar os sons e
ter um vidro é sinal de talento musical
por outro lado os médicos necessitam de
realizar auscultação cardíaca e pulmonar
e também precisão de escutar muito bem
seus pacientes para perceber não sou
aquilo que editio isto é o Manifesto
como também o leite a terceira
característica é que na mitologia grega
o dizer Polo era simultaneamente o Deus
da música e da Medicina EA razão é
porque os gregos acreditavam
é porque música curava alma e ensina
curava os males do corpo também eu na
minha vida tenta integrar estas duas
Artes terapêuticas na minha infância eu
tive a sorte de ter nascido no seio de
uma família com tradição musical e foi
imensamente estimulada para a música era
uma atividade diária que eu realizava
que o meu pai cantávamos e trocávamos eu
acreditava que em todas as famílias a
música Tinha também um papel importante
como tinha na minha família ou não Da
minha adolescência a música foi muito
importante porque ajudavam a regular as
minhas emoções e eu sempre acreditei que
música era importante nas nossas vidas e
assim quando ingressei na faculdade de
medicina da Universidade do porto
procurei saber informar-me sobre estas
duas áreas pelos quase e continua a ter
esta grande paixão a música EA medicina
e foi assim
e ele um artigo da revista das seleções
do reader's digest que falava numa
história inspiradora de uma vez Trina
que tinha sido vítima de AVC a minha
prima estava no hospital em coma e
difere uma ideia aqui do coro infantil
que ela ensaiava fosse cantar para ela
na cama do hospital e o que aconteceu
foi maravilhoso amei as Trina recuperou
do AVC e essa história ficam sempre na
minha memória como em música era muito
importante para a reabilitação e que a
música tinha que realmente um poder
extraordinário ainda desconhecido
passado dois anos a história da
maestrina servir de modelo ou que
aconteceu ao meu avô ele ele sofreu um
AVC fico imóvel que eu em coma no
hospital e nessa altura nós eu e minha
família
e tivemos a ideia de repetir o que
tinham feito com as Trina E nesta
situação Nós levamos uma gravação do meu
avô a tocar porque ele tocava violino e
pusemos com o consentimento da equipa
médica a cassete a tocar depois vai
nesse momento nesse instante em que a
música que o ou na sala no quarto do
hospital o meu avô apertou-me as mãos e
esse momento foi Foi um momento
extraordinário momento que me marcou e e
quando falo nisso repetindo sempre
porque transformou minha vida o meu avô
não Sobreviveu ao AVC ele faleceu
passado uns meses mas naquele dia eu
senti que eu tinha um propósito de vida
e que eu gostaria de compreender como é
que a mente processo
E aí como é que a música Pode ser
terapêutica nas nossas vidas
Oi e sim em 2003 eu ingressei no
internato de pedra psiquiatria no
hospital Dona Estefânia em Lisboa e
aproveitei que estava a viver na capital
para frequentar o mestrado em
neurociências claro que devido ao meu
interesse interessar-me pelas
neurociências da música e realizar um
estudo sobre a percepção dos sons em
doentes com esquizofrenia no início da
doença e pode seria que esses esses
pacientes teriam alteração da percepção
dos sons que poderia servir para Bill
marcadores diagnósticos nesta patologia
mas não se verificaram estas alterações
e portanto não pude concluir nem pode
ser uma ser um marcador biológico
posteriormente ingressei na no Instituto
de Ciências Médicas da Universidade de
Toronto e foi aí que eu realmente
e de fazer uma conjugação das minhas
três paixões a pena o Psiquiatria e as
Crianças com perturbação do espectro do
autismo as neurociências EA música e
assim foi o projeto da minha vida
e o projeto de aterramento consistido
dos estudos não era estudar as bases
neurológicas da audição da música
familiar e o outro era compreender como
é que as crianças com perturbação do
espectro do autismo tencionavam a música
familiar nós sabemos que as crianças com
perturbação do espectro do autismo têm
dificuldades na interação na comunicação
e apresentam comportamentos repetitivos
e muitas vezes tem aversão a novidade
olha por isso música desconhecida e
música familiar era um estímulos
relevantes para estudar e para perceber
como é que estas crianças pertence o não
há novidades utilizando a está a música
O que os resultados mostraram é que
quando essas crianças porque se
percepciona música familiar não há
alterações comparativamente com crianças
controlo da mesma idade mas quando
pertence o não
Oi Cida apresentam alterações na
procissão e aqui podemos demonstrar que
eles realmente têm dificuldades em
processar a novidade aquilo que é
desconhecido em relação o outro estudo
que foi fazer uma revisão sistemática da
literatura e uma meta-análise das áreas
cerebrais que estão ativas quando nós
ouvimos música familiar o estudo mostrou
que as áreas que são mais ativadas são
as áreas motoras as áreas promotoras e
área da memória é Nossa interpretação é
quando nós ouvimos uma música familiar
nós já conhecemos já sabemos o que é que
segue na música e por isso a uma
sincronização áudio motora que nos
prepara para o movimento de cantar de
dançar bater palmas bater o pé ou seja
de nos mexermos ao som do Ritmo e ao som
da música e isso importante
O que é importante é importante porque
pode ser muito objetivo na reabilitação
motora de doentes neurológicos Há muitos
profissionais que usam a música com esse
fim posso citar o trabalho da Professora
Doutora Ana Cristina Vidal
fisioterapeuta do hospital Garcia de
orta é que lidera uma equipa que
utilizam a música como um estímulo
neurossensorial na reabilitação de
doentes com AVC e é um caso publicado de
um nutriente que o sono da kizomba Teve
uma recuperação muito mais rápida e
eficaz isto porque ela ouvir música
familiar alto kizomba reativou
movimentos automáticos que estavam bem
consolidade antes da lesão com AVC E
assim se mostra os benefícios da música
ou seja de uma arte na saúde eu não sou
eu tenho dedicado muito esta temática
das Artes na saúde e no ano passado em
novembro de 2019 a OMS Organização
Mundial de Saúde fiz um estudo exaustivo
sobre os benefícios da arte na saúde e à
conclusão que chegou após essa revisão
de cerca de 900 artigos é que a Dotz e
Mais especificamente a música porque a
música Era arte que se foi mais bem
estudada é que a música é importante não
só na gestão e no tratamento de doenças
mas também é importante na promoção e
prevenção e do nosso bem-estar e
importante para o nosso desenvolvimento
humano e eu posso dar aqui três exemplos
como é que a música é importante um
desenvolvimento humano
e por exemplo nem Infância os nossos
pais falam conosco enquanto papéis
utilizando uma linguagem muito musical e
esta Musicalidade é importante para o
vínculo para a ligação e para a
proximidade entre os pais e o bebé além
disso a música facilita a aquisição eo
desenvolvimento da linguagem mais tarde
na adolescência a música muito
importante porque dá uma uma identidade
e ajudando na coesão do grupo e nós como
adultos adoramos ouvir música porque faz
me sentir bem e lá está a música tem um
papel extraordinário na regulação das
nossas emoções e que nós percebemos que
a música Tem um alto valor biológico ou
seja se a música não fosse importante já
se teria desaparecido da face da terra
por isso a música sem a sua razão de
existir e posso dizer com
o cientista que a circuitos neuronais
específicos para a música que são
completamente Independentes da linguagem
e a teoria evolucionista tem se dedicado
nos últimos anos é compreender melhor a
relação entre música e a linguagem
a que horas de Halloween por exemplo
acreditava que andas a música linguagem
derivavam de uma própria linguagem que
não outros investigadores acreditaram e
acreditam que a música é linguagem tiver
10 origens e evoluções completamente
Independentes há quem Ache que a música
evoluída linguagem e por fim a quem acha
que a linguagem evolui da música pessoas
como eu que acreditam Porque existe um
provérbio africano que diz se sabe falar
então só cantar e
[Música]